foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone how are you guys
doing
are you guys enjoying from yesterday's
session
lot of exciting news huh
so now let's get into the business today
I'm going to talk about how you can make
money by using apis
and this session is going to be allowed
by your CFO all your expenses will be
covered immediately so this is the first
time I'm going to talk about how you can
monetize your assets using apis
my name is Jay burchella I'm the product
manager for RPG I've been with avici for
almost four years and I've been in the
API space for almost 10 years
I'm really excited about this topic I
manage a lot of opposite data products
and conferences and more intention is
very close to my heart and I work with
hundreds of customers across the globe
and I help them to monetize their apis
today I'm going to have a
one second
I'm really delighted to share stage with
one of the Google's longest earning
partner
um
funded by Google Ventures and RPG
customer above all they use Marketplace
orientation product and 400 and CEO of
Rocket Lawyer rocket liar is online
legal services company I don't want to
steal the Thunder from Charlie so
Charlie is going to go back and start
talk about their company and how they've
been successful with RPG then I'll come
back and started explaining about the
whole process what are the challenges
that customers are faced the startups
are facing when they are trying to scale
and they're trying to monetize their
values assets on it in the end we are
going to have some key and a sessions so
if you want to have questions come
please come to the stage and we can take
some key and here after the session I'll
be here for a couple of minutes then we
are going to be at the startup launch so
without further Ado please welcome me
joining uh Charlie Moore
thank you
well thank you Jay uh you you're
definitely a hard act to follow
um it's uh it's exciting to be here uh
talking about
uh one of my favorite subjects so apis
are core to our business strategy uh
really moving the flywheel uh it's a way
for us to externalize and be a force
multiplier
um for our entire business and our
mission
so at Rocket Lawyer we make the law
affordable and simple for everybody uh
you know everybody should know I mean I
usually talk about being a recovering
high-priced lawyer you know I was a
Silicon Valley lawyer before I started
the company
uh you know charging hundreds if not
thousands of dollars an hour uh most
startups can't even really afford that
and so our mission is to make law
affordable and to make the basic tools
of Justice affordable for most people
Justice isn't you know whether you
whether you go to jail and that's a
great thing Justice for most people is
whether you can put things in writing
whether you can have contracts for your
business whether your business can be
incorporated have the benefit of limited
liability protection uh whether you're
whether whether or not as an employee at
a company you know what better way to
get the benefits of Affordable Legal
Services than to get it as a benefit of
employment and we're very proud that
every Google employee for example
Google's one of our longest standing
customers every Google employee gets
Rocket Lawyer as employee benefit as
well as every stripe employee in every
uh sales force employee and about a
thousand other companies so apis are
Central to this strategy of how we
expand our each by going to our
customers where they are whether it's
because they're employed somewhere or
whether for example they're a customer
of of another cloud service we want to
integrate with them uniquely also with
Rocket Lawyer we're a global company you
know it's difficult to make law a global
Service in an integrated fashion the
incumbents typically would go acquire
you know here's the legal document
company in Germany or here's the legal
document company and the Netherlands or
what have you but I'm very proud to say
the rocketler has expanded organically
outside our homework in the United
States again using our API platform our
Technologies
instead of doing this sort of hodgepodge
all around the world and so as a result
one in four French citizens can get
access to rocketlord through a
partnership we have with covia which is
one of the largest Insurance Groups in
France it has about 11 million people
insured in the United States Adobe
document Cloud now has integrated Rocket
Lawyer apis and about one in nine
Americans has registered with us and
created a free account with Rocket
Lawyer and about a million people have
paid accounts with Rocket Lawyer some
through their employer some through
there through API partners and some that
we acquire directly so why apis
well the first thing I'm going to say is
I I see a couple of our senior engineers
in the audience Chris and Brian and you
know these guys are what it's all about
thank you guys these guys actually wrote
some of the talking points that I have
here so
um uh it's fun for me to to basically be
up here and explain things that those
guys do but why apis because it makes
people like Brian and Chris more
effective uh at Rocket lure
um why apogee apis will let me tell you
we started uh initially uh by creating
our own API Gateway and I know Brian
Cruz are both around for that we we
create our own API Gateway
um as sort of a proof of concept but
then once you know you're the dog that
catches the bus once you get you know
customers like Adobe or customers like
that who want to be third-party
developers on your
um platform uh that your homegrown API
or at least for us it just wasn't good
enough so I mentioned uh our partners in
France large French insurance company
our own homegrown API platform we know
isn't isn't going to cut the muster for
that over the long term so we'll be
transitioning that partnership over to
the apogee apis as well one of the
biggest things that for me as a CEO
um was concerning was security
uh and so I would say probably the two
biggest issues are security and
monetization you want to make sure that
uh especially in today's world you know
I even saw yesterday there were some
hacking attempts going on at this
conference so
um you want to make sure that you have
world-class security as you sort of uh
become successful or at least as our as
we became successful and maybe I should
switch aside at this point but as we
became more successful it had more uh
developers interested in our apis
especially uh the bigger companies big
you know the global 1000 size businesses
interested the due diligence that those
companies do is uh world class and so
you know that with a partner or we knew
that with a partner like apogee we were
going to need a front door that had been
through that a million times and maybe
the partners used for their API gateways
for their own Services as well and it's
going to be best in class so that was
another big reason for us of why apis
but also why apogee is a particular
partner
now what what do what do we get out of
it or what does a partner get out of it
well there are multiple facets in the
workflow that we support the most
important of course is legal
documentation for us so creating
contracts with machine learning with
assisted
making it easy for somebody to just
answer a few simple questions and then
uh that the software does the rest so
legal documentation is at the core of
Rocket Lawyer just like it is in a legal
system in the world
now around that we have other services
like uh
rocket sign digital signature service we
have other services uh like rocket file
which enables you to do filings with
government agencies like incorporations
trademarks Etc we also have ask which
enables you to ask a lawyer all of those
components of of the overall workflow
may be useful to an API partner
discreetly individually and so with our
API Gateway we're able to then separate
out these distinct services use apogee
as the front door and then enable
partners for example we have a number of
prop prop tech companies these are
companies that support
landlords and folks that are in the
rental property business what's the
thing what do they need they need leases
sometimes they need to evict tenants
they need attorney advice they need
digital signatures so they can really
get an A La Carte menu the the partners
for us that are property tech companies
for example they can get an A La Carte
menu and say yeah I want to power leases
in the state of Nevada or wherever using
the Rocket Lawyer API and it comes very
easy for them to then create a front-end
integration for their customers but
using our back-end document service for
that they can do the same thing with
rocket SCI and over time we we now
build everything API first and let me
yeah so we build everything API first
this is a good example right lease
agreement everything API first so all of
our uh we have our service oriented
architecture we really
um for the last 10 years made that an
absolute discipline in our uh in in the
way we build in the way we architect
everything and as a business that sells
direct to con consumers ourselves uh I
mentioned we have about 30 million
account holders in the United States so
we sell direct to Consumers ourselves
and then we have API Partners what's
fantastic now is we can tell our API
Partners what you are operating on what
you're building your uh front-end
services on is this are the same
back-end services that we build on top
of as well and so that gives the partner
a lot of confidence it also cuts down on
the maintenance and support
that we have to provide as we are able
to uh operate on exactly the same back
end infrastructure that our that our
partners are and using the exact same
apis as our partners
um
maybe a couple more words about why
apogee and then I'll hand the mic over
to Jay let's see if I have even no okay
so I'll stay here for a second
um again security I've talked a fair
amount about but monetization so
um with with a partner like apogee we
automatically have a way to look at
um at least three different ways to
monetize
uh what we sell
typically most of our larger Partners
now will elect to have some sort of rate
metering approach so we have a number of
partners that we that have this sort of
rate metering approach either Based on
data or based on some actions that are
being powered by the API we also have
Partners uh that are on a revenue share
sort of approach and then uh in the
future you know we may uh we may or may
not look at some of the other uh
monetization sort of Hybrid models that
I know apogee's working on but again it
makes it a lot easier for us to have a
partner that um that can support
monetization and security the way that
we want to do it so I'll give it back to
you and
thanks thanks Charlie
so let's find out new ways to uh Revenue
with Refugee API management not only
just generating Revenue how you can even
go ahead and started scaling and today
we are going to go and talk about how
you can make your first dollar without
spending and time isn't it great so
that's what we will be focusing on it so
the scaling your value is very hard
problem so the data shows like 42
percent of startups
trying to uh lack of the right Market
fit you can have a great team an amazing
funding great board and great technology
but if you don't have the right Market
fit product and if you go to market with
only one or couple of hero features then
you will be started struggling with the
right Market fit yes you can go ahead
and start it selling but can you scale
it can you add the value to the entire
Market on that can you go to the global
on that can you adjust different markets
on that one with your
um similar with your limited experiences
that's one bigger problem and the 74 the
percent of the customers
they struggle to capture the market by
going the premature scaling so
before they even started analyzing
Market they started investing on the
entire scale the infrastructure on it
like the way the Charlie was telling
like okay they started building their
own API Gateway and then they realized
that one okay this is not our core
competency why don't we just go ahead
and piggyback and the specialist product
on it so that is one example on that one
so what is your core capability and when
you need to go ahead and scale it and
the customer acquisition cost from the
last five years has been increased by 50
percent on it so these are the some of
the major challenges that startups are
facing under so how do we solve this one
the for
identifying the lack of right Market fit
I didn't say the what is the value
proportion on that one it is not the
finished service whether you are
creating a website whether you are
creating an app or wherever you're
creating your own service on that one
what are the underlying value proportion
assets you have that one let's identify
that one we will walk through step by
step on that one the second one is
come up with an approach like a try more
fail fast how quickly you can go back
and started developing on that one and
can you go back and start a reusable
conference and can we go back and start
it using a
um the uh
the framework that is being offered by
the cloud providers online and also in
order to increase in order to reduce the
customer acquisition cost can you go
back and started partnering with
different customers on the different
partners on that one especially in the
developer ecosystem so can you go back
and start it offering your services into
someone else's experience on that one so
can you go back and start integrating
with like Banks and finances or some
third party crms is all it available so
it can go back and started integrating
with them
so in order to do that so we laid out
the fourth simple Foundation four simple
ways you can do that one is expand your
product
so your product is not the finished
service that you are offering with one
or two hero features on it it is a
mobile application so your product
cannot be just mobile application only
because there are a lot of details there
are a lot of value assets that is
powering your app so you need to
identify that so whenever I go to
customers about talking about
orientation they ask me like okay I have
this data what do you want me to go back
and start it uh how do you want me to go
back and started exposing on that first
you need to info what are the key value
propositions that your product has been
in the second one is accelerate
development with standard protocols on
it so go back and start it and stop you
developing everything with proprietary
and try to reuse the standard ways of
accessing your data and capabilities and
API is the key here and third one is
enhance your product offering by
integrating with third-party services on
that so there are a bunch of third party
services that there so can you go back
and start doing that for example Payment
Processing so can you go back and build
your own Payment Processing or can you
go back and start using like a stripe or
paper or something like that one plus
one is always greater than two and it
works great in this scenario and third
one is
and hence expand your customer rage
by integrating by integrating with the
partners on it so
there is a famous African saying if you
wanted to go fast go alone
if you wanted to go far go together
plant thus Partnerships can help you a
long way so they can help you to go and
address the market that you cannot go
along on this
so let's find out what is your valid
disk assets on that one so in this case
let's take a simple application
so you created one simple application
and in this scenario I will take an app
that create that does the translation so
it does the three translations one it
translates from
text to different language say text to
span English to Spanish or it can take
English word to Spanish language or it
can take a English document and
translate to Spanish documentation it's
simple so you can go back and start
offering as a translation service on
that
once you do this yes you can go back and
create an app and start offering to
Consumers that's it that's the market
that you're going to go ahead and so
what else you can go back and start
offering more so is there anything else
that can I can come back and start it
monetizing on that one so let's identify
what are the
um core value assets that your product
really brings on that one so and first
started identifying and how what are the
core capitals here the core capabilities
in this scenario is the translation
service the text voice as well as
document translation service that is the
one the second one is what data you are
really presenting to the back to the
customer on it so can I go back and
start monetizing on that one so what
data your community is contributing to
your applications are that so can you go
back and started using the community on
this so when you started looking at that
then your product is not only offering
as a single solution to Consumer it can
all you can also go back and started
selling the data to a particular
industry on that say for example Health
the translation for healthcare will be
completely different for media that
translate some of the Lexington
dictionaries that you use for a
particular vertical you can monetize for
that or you can also go back and create
an apis where your community they can go
back and give you the feedback to you so
if any translation problems then
Community go back and give you the
feedback on that and also you can
leverage this community developer
Community or user Community they can
leverage user Community to translate on
behalf of you so if your engine is not
performing well you can go back and use
them as mechanical type they can do it
for you so these are the multiple ways
you can identify the data so once you
identify this capabilities now bring all
these cabled as an apis for that
then the apis are going to be front door
for your business
so now all I've Sharon
till now you had only one solution which
was a mobile application the language
the translation mobile application by
doing that now you have multiple
applications one is the app and also the
API products so your app can go to your
original business case but your APS can
go to wherever your partners can go so
that is the that is how you go back and
started solving the market fit problem
on it so couple of examples for that so
what you can expose with the apis so API
is whenever people talk about APS or I
can expose the data so I can go back and
give the data in Json reality that is
not an entirely true I know that's very
major cases on that
then APS you can also expose the your
technology through API sometime so my
favorite API and I always call like
Tesla free APS which failure so I came
from Telco background I have partiality
towards Julio so tillio they offer
entire Telco functionality in form of
APs an amazing ABS on that the same
thing for payment processing stripe is
one example and also uh one of my
favorite customer and super successful
through pubg is AccuWeather so whenever
you see any weather related information
in a web any website the chance of that
website is being powered or an app being
powered by AccuWeather on this and a lot
of students also use the RPC AccuWeather
APN is so a key whether they send
weather related information to the
customer on it not only recently uh APS
are being used not just to expose the
functionality not just to expose the
data and also they are using for viralty
also so the Shopify is one of the
example on that so you can expose the
apis so that they can go back and
started exposing their products that is
being sold through Shopify
how do we go back and convert your APS
into channels of Revenue so now we
created API product it's great now we
have okay now how do I how can I go back
and start making money so Jay you said
so many things now show me the money
right so once you create the API product
so I'm busy uh is the API management how
many of you use the RPG as of now please
raise your hands
good thank you so now once you create
the APA product
um through appraising then you package
those API paths what is the API product
the opposite DNA is we treat every
single AP as a product so every time we
talk about APA we call like APA product
it's a digital asset for any digital
asset the couple of characteristics
right it's a definition of how the API
that product really works how to use the
product and how to
sell it how you can go ahead and price
that one so RPG offers the you can go
back and create AP product and we
provide the framework we provide the
tool set so that you can set a price
plan for that how really wanted to go
back into that we can deep dive inside
that later so once you started offering
API product to customers through
developer portal then
somebody of the partner or developer is
going to start consuming inside their
services or application so we're not
really stopping there so obviously
collects tons of data through this flow
so we provide analytics with fried grain
details and that we provide multiple
ways of
analyzing the traffic and who are the
customers are using on that the latency
performance the revenue which geography
is being used which app is being used
that what are my popular apis uh being
used which application is being my hero
app and how do I go by whether this
price plan is working or not how am I
going to go back and start fixing the
price plan or can I kick up the new
marketing campaign all these 90 ads
being covered by FZ
so for a minute let's start thinking
about like outside in like I said before
like whenever I meet a customer most of
the time they ask like hey I have this
this Assets in my backyard or my um
database I wanted a go ahead and expose
this one for a minute you need to go
back and started thinking about and
start with the customer
so if you always started thinking with
your assets you always will be ended up
going to the one or two markets but if
you started really thinking about the
customers okay where is the market and
how many ways we can reach the customer
so if if you started thinking about the
customer then you started thinking about
okay can I go back and address all these
customers with my application or my
service or can I go back and started
partnering on that one so that is how
you started thinking about the
um outside in then once he started
identifying okay these are the 10
services that I need to go back and
address these are the 10 service that I
need to be partnered on that then you
create an APA product so once you create
an API product then as an APA Team all
your responsibility is all about like
provide a better API design and make
sure the customers developers are going
to be started using on it and also
started creating a demand for your apis
treat APA product like your finished
product on it so provide the better
documentation and engage with the user
and drive the demand for that
now let's start talking about how do you
package uh apis into products on it so
in apa monetization is a feature in RPG
and we have hundreds of customers using
the product so once you create APA
product then we have a feature called
transaction policy so we will allow
developer API provider to pick and
choose what the API transaction has to
be monetized it's not that like we
create AP product we are going to go
back and started monetizing every single
call on that so we'll by default we
started offering but we also offer you
the benefit of like pick and choose what
API product is being monetized and what
API product has been not monetized and
also you can even
change the value of transaction by the
payload size also so
if an APA call is giving like some
amount of data then you go back and
start charging a dollar if another API
call is giving like y amount of data you
can charge differently too
so once you create the API product then
you can go back and start it creating
the price plan I will get more details
in the price plan it's very exciting one
then once we started offering then we
will give uh once the transaction is
going through the gateway then we
started doing magic here we started
doing the real time majoring and we
started doing the real time enforcement
say for example if there is any if they
exceed their quota say for example like
you're offering thousand API calls for
000 API calls for hundred dollars a
month so once they reach that quota then
the next AP call will be blocked or in
case of prepaid customers and if the
balance is low then we are going to
block the next API call on that so we
will ensure that we are not only just
doing metering we will also do the
enforcement also
and everything is great but in the end
you really need a bill right we have
multiple tools multiple APS out on
internal apis so that you can go ahead
and generate the invoice on that in
addition to the billing apis we're also
integrating with a looker and so using a
looker RPG customers they can go back
and started generating reports and
invoices then you can send these
invoices
the Second Step here is standardize
access to backend service what do you
mean this standardizing access to
backend service on that everything
whatever the services that you are
exposing whether that is internal or
whether you are really reaching the
external customer or whatever the
experience that you go back and started
creating and make sure you ask your
backend services using apis by creating
apis you will have a better control with
the help of RPG API management platform
it improves the developer experiences
and it increase the facility and
Innovation and it improves the security
because RPG is really good in handling
authentication authorization and
auditing purpose and also it will help
you to scale
because RPC works with the features on
load balancing and caching so it will
help you to scale it scale too
always try to use third party services
and third party
um
products on it so in order to do that
you really do not need to go back and
started using their apis like that so we
have a great product called RPG
application integration so if you have
data CRM data and Salesforce or sap so
you can always go back and start it we
exposed bunch of connectors so those
connectors uh RPG application sorry
Google application integration platform
it connects those third board
applications through connectors then
that is automatically with seamlessly
integrate with your apis that with
limited efforts you can integrate with
your apis then your API is not only
using your functionality and it can also
go back and started using third-party
services too so for example tracking so
you can integrate with FedEx or you can
integrate with UPS services on that so
our connectors really helps on that so
this is where your solution as well as
third parties Solutions can take you to
the next level
well the last one is the how do we go
back and solve the customer operation
problem for that you really don't need
um huge Salesforce to do that so in
order for you to sell your API products
all you need is simple developer
developer portal RPG offers three types
of developer for portals one is the
built-in integrated developer portal
easy to use and the second one is uh
Drupal based developer portal and where
you can if you are handy with the Drupal
development and you can go back and
start creating developer portal but if
it really insist to have your own portal
and we do provide the entire API
management apis so that you can build
your own fancy developer portal too so
once you develop the develop one of the
reason why developer portal is really
famous is it will help you to reduce the
onboarding efforts by 10 times this is
the data that we received from our
customers on that one a good developer
portal will help you to onboard the
partners on that like AccuWeather they
have hundreds and hundreds and thousands
of developers they have it so they've
been doing amazing job on that and also
um developer portal really helps you to
engage with your partners on it so for
example if you create an API product
engage with your customers through
sample code and Sample applications on
it good documentation real-time feedback
from your partners on that forums you
can also go back one step above and you
can even use that API developer API
product information and portal as a
marketing tool for you
now let's talk about like you created
um you created APA product and you
integrated with the internal uh
third-party Solutions now we created a
developer portal so how do I go back and
started showing like how the customer
really comes back and started using so
RPG offers
variety of pricing models on it so one
is like a very popular is a fee based
pricing model the fee based pricing
model is basically uh it can be done
through transaction so for every single
APA call I wanted to charge it dollar so
that is simple transaction and very
super easy to use on that or the second
one is also called
a tier based pricing the first AP calls
is dollar the next 100 APA calls is 50
Cents the third 300 API calls 200 to 300
APA calls is 25 cents the more they use
the price will change so you defined
that logic in our rate plan management
tool then we take behind the scenes once
we Define then we know what product is
being used what trade they've been
purchased and when they do the metering
we apply the entire logic and we make
sure every transaction has been metered
properly so like Charlie said another
popular use case is revenue share so
there are times where your partner can
take your product to your customers
store their customers and they bring the
direct Revenue to you so Telco is one of
the popular example on this so whenever
they really wanted to go back and
started selling more data to customers
so one way they can sell the data they
can can go back and start offering
through their stores or Telco websites
but there are times where customers
started charging for the data every 10
gigs of data is 10 or something then a
lot of game developer game apps they
started using Telco apis when they're
really busy in game when they're running
out of low on the data then they use the
Telco apis and they go back and get more
they buy the more data on behalf of the
user game user and then they started
charging the user so they get the
revenue share on that one and the last
one is freemium
who don't like free stuff right so the
same with Partners too so if you really
wanted to make your API product gets
excited
give them some free APA calls or let you
let them use your API product for X
number of days or make it both
combination of both like auto warranty
right it's 30 000 miles or five years
whichever comes first and we do offer
the all three varieties of Premium
capabilities too
so once you offer this and I really want
to go back and start to talk a little
bit more about
um
how what type of customers are there so
we identified three different sections
of customers so RPG offers both prepaid
billing model as well as postpaid
billing model so let me go back a little
bit and see which one is good for whom
so first paid a prepaid price Model we
always recommend to long tail developers
where they don't have enough credit
where you are really not sure if you
really want to go back and started
engaging its partnership level with each
and every customer so that's where we're
really encourage prepaid model and pre
in prepaid model and RPG integrates with
a couple of popular API Gateway sorry
payment Gateway platforms such as wall
ping and if you are a Drupal developer
and we do integrate with Drupal Commerce
margin so Drupal Commerce module takes
hundreds of payment methods and we
support that one too so the second one
is called a partnership program so where
you go back and engage the partner and
partner is going to come and started
using the aps end of the month you will
be sending the invoice to them and they
they will send the bill to you this more
kind of like payment
postgrade model and the third one and
it's becoming very popular I strongly
recommend if you haven't tried and is
called credit based pricing the credit
base pricing is
usually
usually the sales team and even the
finance team don't want to change the
price of their product very often on it
so you don't want to go back and set
like your API product is for every
single AP call is a dollar and later
they started changing that one to 50
cents or even if you started seeing more
demand you started going up going back
and changing that into two dollars on
that instead of that you can always tell
them like okay in order to use this APA
call you need to pay x amount of credit
so 10 credits for every single AP call
on it but the way how the customer
acquires those credits can be vary from
customer to customer the private private
pricing is super common in this world so
every single customer they pay different
price for their service on that so on
the front side every single developers
every single partner will see 10 cents
10 credits for every single API call but
when they give the ten dollars some cash
too much they get for 10 10 credits for
ten dollars different customers they get
20 credits and third customers they can
get 100 credits on that one so you will
have that flexibility on this so this is
becoming really popular and a lot of
customers started using it
so now let's put all our uh ideas and
thoughts into simple example then I
really wanted to see how it's going to
work together on this so let's say we
have a company called
Cloud9 and it's in a fictitious image
Processing Company so that it takes
images or series of images and it
identify the patterns and it will tell
you like okay
um if the picture has any kind of like
uh defects that can be there or it can
identify some particular patterns on
that so there are multiple ways you can
do that right going back like okay you
can create an app someone is going to
upload the app or website someone can
upload the website and you offer the
service like every single uh image that
you upload you can offer that or you can
also take the core functionality and
expose an API then you started selling
that API so let the customers started
going back and started using those apis
in their own application so one of the
classical example is checkup Checker is
the API company so who does the
background check their entire business
model is about API only so all they do
is just give the API and they started
doing the background so once you
identify once you identify the core
competency of like image recognition API
then you started building the API
product around that so once you build
the API product go back and started
creating that rate plan
in this case we will pick like Freeway
model the first 10
AP calls is free then you started
charging 10 cents for every single API
call so that's the product then once we
create the API product and go ahead and
start publishing in
publishing in the developer portal by
the way the way how we publish is see
the developer portal is completely
seamless on it the minute you publish
your Avi product and it will be
automatically shown in
uh developer portal the minute you
started changing your price plan in RPC
it will automatically reflected in the
developer portal for that so it will be
automatically seamlessly integrated with
that so once the developer started using
your API product then
um we provide bunch of tools where you
can go back and start it monitoring the
API performance and you can start it
analyzing the API consumption and also
you can go back and start it analyzing
the revenue we provide a lot of tools
for you to be successful online
so this is the testimony from one of our
customer AccuWeather
the theme of this testimonies never
underestimate a small apartment A small
time developer on that long tail
developer so if your API is really doing
good that small time developer can turn
out with a big Enterprise partner on it
so Google
can you hear me
yeah so Google offering multiple
incentives for startups and please use
this QR code and if you have any
questions and go to Startup launch and
they can give you a lot of they can give
you a lot of details and incentive for
startups at different stages on it
and please do provide your feedback and
so we'll open a session for question and
answers Charlie and myself we will be
here and we'll take a couple of
questions on it
thank you